there is this guy right here in Florida
Ron DeSantis here he is explaining how
he will hold Disney accountable for what
they did and actually how this is
connected to everything that we've
discussed over the last 40 minutes or so
so
um you know what I said was last year uh
that Disney will no longer have its own
government Disney will live under the
same laws as everybody else and Disney
will pay the debts and taxes and that's
exactly what's going to happen so the
question was always is it going to be
under State control or local control I
actually initially when we did the bill
to Sunset it and we knew we were going
to take additional action I was agnostic
between those but then what started
happening was you at Orange County
saying they were going to raise people's
taxes by thousands of dollars and doing
this now I think that was all a dog and
pony show but then I'm thinking to
myself is that really something that
that I want to uh allow them to be able
to do do I trust them being able to
handle the Municipal debt and all this
stuff and so I'm not I I'm not I don't
have a lot of confidence in that so it's
going to be a state control board
there's absolutely
there's absolutely going to be
accountability uh the corporate Kingdom
has come to an end and that will be the
case when this is enacted
[Applause]
look whether it is fighting the ideas of
the world economic forum and one
government to rule us all one ring to
rule us all or whether it's the governor
of Florida going after one of the giant
corporations in the world and you may
remember you may remember this is less
than a year ago with this whole don't
say gay nonsense came out and Disney was
going all in on trying to destroy
DeSantis and everything else everybody
in the mainstream media was siding with
Disney and saying you can't defeat
Disney and this is going to hurt
DeSantis at The Ballot Box because
they're in Orlando and they have found
30 000 employees in Florida or something
like that and you can't fight their
money and you can't fight their
influence and he did it and he won by 20
points Disney stock is crashing they're
coming crawling back to him Bob Iger the
new CEO who replaced the guy Bob chapic
who was who was basically us hostage
from his woke employees Iger is now
reversing course on some of what they're
doing with their programming so you can
win but you got to get involved whatever
that means to you
[Music]